[Music]
his sense of style is always on point is
something no one has ever said about him
it's true he makes hobos look like sharp
dressed men give a big round of applause
for our friend comedian jimmy fella
yo
you guys
i gotta tell you i love nashville
because it's the only city where you can
answer every single question with whoo
and everyone knows what you're talking
about
you don't say exactly
yeah no no this is a party town man i
was driving home last night at cop stop
me he's like you drink an alcohol sir i
was like no he's like all right here you
go handed me a six-pack
but it's cool to be here you know
although it is a hard time to be a comic
like i want you to know that for us
right now people are treating jokes like
hate crimes like way too serious
everybody's obsessed with words they're
always changing the language where i'm
from new york you can't even call a
pervert a pervert anymore you have to
call them governor cuomo
but i'm saying man and i don't do a lot
of politics in my act the only real
advice i would ever give you uh from
experience is never buy a used car off
elizabeth warren um
i had a buddy in massachusetts she sold
him a red jeep cherokee we ran the
carfax turned out to be a white suburban
and uh
but but but but i'm telling you dude
like i know we're trying to be a nicer
society but a lot of the things we're
doing in the name of political
correctness are hurting us as a people
i'll give you an example i wrote a study
the other day that 40 of elementary
school kids are obese but they're not
doing anything about it because they
don't know they're obese think about
that they don't know yo that's what
happens when you eliminate bullying
think about it back in the day every one
of those fat kids would have known they
were fat
they would have went on a high protein
diet and turned their lives around but
no now we have a nation full of seven
year old man boobs because he can't call
names
but hold on for real like i'm telling
you because i care i was the beneficiary
of a tough love society name's help like
i was fat as a kid i weighed 300 pounds
i did something about it because i knew
i was fat every day when i got dropped
off that car you know at school every
day the minute i got out of that car hey
you fat slob how much you can eat today
you disgusting animal and i'd be like
all right mom i'll see you at three i'll
see you
i guess
and you can rough your kid up to turn
him around nobody turns it around
anymore it's a mess man you know the
only upside to all these fat kids is
kidnappings are down like 94 right now
because you can't get them in the car
you can't it's a crime of speed
and uh can you imagine being a kidnapper
in this day and age you're like kid i
got candy get in the van and the kid's
like does it contain peanuts
[Laughter]
is there any high fructose corn syrup
and a mars bar
but it scares me because like i feel
like with all this woke stuff we're
raging such like a fragile generation of
people and like that scares me because
america is in the ass kick in business
you know and 20 years from now we have a
military that's like oh my god isis
called me an infidel i am not fighting
today
hate has no home on this battlefield
mister you know
like where i'm from up north people like
to make fun of southern rednecks yo i
thank god for rednecks every day you
want to know why though for real oh you
guys
you guys
you guys
but i do because you're the only ones
raising tough kids anymore you know if
isis shows up tomorrow you ain't calling
hudson hopper and zayn you know what i'm
saying
you're calling bobby joe bubba and
cletus
and they're gonna take out isis using
rifles they got for their 10th birthday
you know that
thank you but that's how it's gonna go
down the redneck babies are gonna take
on isis the hipster babies are gonna
battle the evil forces of gluten you
know what i'm saying
all right you guys were amazing i'm
jimmy phil have a good night you guys
all right
jimmy fail everyone awesome job hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else